[Musique]
enfin les enfants bourreaux soient
j'apporte une surprise devenu tout ce
que ce pour le cheval
[Musique]
mais une souris ont secoué dans l'herbe
j'ai la trappe attaque ou lolo jean-paul
chela mais pas moi beaumont c'est
monsieur m'a dit mettez la dans l'huile
nous mettez la dans l'eau
louvier masque gauche a tout
vu de vider dans laquelle de mes pattes
se trouve lescar pau
mais quel est ce garde celui que j'ai
apportée oui un vrai deux vidéos
à la
série si nous apporter un escargot
plutôt rêveur
mais
de celle ci non pas celle là hop hop hop
au menu vous doko
scellerait la bravo vous avez gagné
[Musique]
près de l'est plutôt une belle feuille
de salade et tu verras il va sortir pour
la manger tard et zone of classe s 400 m
la salle
voilà pour ma
dénonce ça s'apprivoise un escargot
certainement mais celui ci va retourner
à la campagne
oui ce soir un escargot est plus heureux
dans l'herbe en liberté dans les champs
à l'eau
maintenant que tu as bien rangée route
chantier jusqu'en mai
a partagé sa course en voyage merci les
enfants n'a pas allons nous coucher il
est à beaune nuits de noce
voyage jusqu'à
co2
[Musique]
que fais-tu avec cette salade nounours
ceux pour les escargots pas trop quelle
escargots celui que je tenais dans ma
patte
dépêchons-nous de partir je le ramène
dans sa campagne en route bonnut des
enfants rendre assez bien fort vos
parents du football
[Musique]
et
vous
[Musique]